[Music]
English lessons today's mini English
lesson is about word stress I just want
to be a pee huh desert is my favorite
thing
some people have school for beer mmm
when you learn new words in English
always check how many syllables there
are in the world this is not always
connected to the number of letters in
the word the word scratched has unites
letters with only one syllable the word
idea has four letters with three
syllables once you check the number of
syllables in a word you need to check
which syllable is the most important and
that's what we call the stressed
syllable word stress is not about stress
it's about what's important when we talk
about wanting to be a P what we really
want to say is I just want to be happy
the stress in the two syllable word
happy is on the first syllable you can
make it like this ha the stressed
syllable should be louder longer higher
and clearer than the other syllables in
the work in the other example desert is
my favorite thing it's kind of strange I
think what you want to say is desert is
my favorite thing mmm now that I can
understand suza is a two syllable word
with the stress on the second syllable
you can do it like this desert and how
about school forbid sounds great but I
think you probably want to say school
phobia that's a three syllable word with
the stress on the first syllable phobia
not severe
so how do you know which syllables to
stress luckily there are some patterns
in two syllable nouns and adjectives
normally the stress would be on the
first syllable like Apple or bottle in
two syllable words normally the stress
would be on the second syllable creates
some words look the same but one form
might be a noun or adjectives and the
other form is a verb and the stress
changes accordingly
perfect the adjective perfect when we
change that to a verb the stress changes
to the second syllable perfect I have to
perfect my work so it will be perfect
some other words might change their
meaning unexpectedly depending on where
you put the stress if you're someone who
writes information for websites or books
you might call yourself a content
creator a content creator if you get the
stress wrong and you tell everybody that
you're a content creator you mean that
you're happy
well that's great and I'm pleased for
you but what do you make now that you
know all about work stress remember that
you can always be a peep
[Music]